[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast today was a real treat
um super grateful for this interview
with Michael a singer he wrote a book
that you may have heard of it is my
favorite book that I recommend to
everybody called the untethered Soul he
also wrote a book called The Surrender
experiment and his newest is called
living untethered he also mastered in
economics and was an extremely
successful businessman he now has uh
yoga and meditation center called Temple
of the universe and Michael was just
such a delight sometimes you interview
people and you're just you you're so
excited and it is so hard for people to
top your excitement level sometimes when
you've read their books and you know who
they are and you followed them and he
did he really did he was such a
delightful human so humble practical
deep sweet and
um just so wise I mean his advice
sometimes it feels so simple and thank
God it's simple
um because those are the things that we
need to practice it doesn't mean they're
easy
um to get Beyond yourself and practice
these things but they're absolutely
simple and today he explains all of
those ways of getting beyond our self of
being able to access the Observer of
being able to process the mess and the
junk that we push down why we push it
down how to let it flow through us and
essentially how to live a happier life
how to not be how to not take things
personally how to not be triggered like
can you imagine living a life where
those things didn't happen anymore and
it's possible it's possible with these
practices and um and so then of course
we talked about what's the final
destination what does it look like when
you finally get to where you're supposed
to go and what it does that even exist
so it's just a really beautiful
conversation and highly recommend
getting all of his books and reading
them in the meantime enjoy this deep
dive conversation with Michael a singer
wonderful human being please hit
subscribe hit the bell for notifications
let me know what you think in the
comments I can't wait to read them and
and hear what resonated with you please
enjoy this conversation oh my gosh when
you said when I said how you doing you
said ecstatic I'm like you live your
work I just said your answer was
ecstatic
how do you achieve ecstatic I taught you
in the book I know I know it's if there
is
one book that I recommend to people the
number one book that I recommend to
people is the untethered soul that is
the one they're like if there was one
that would help me the most what would
it be
unlike this one just being able to get
Beyond yourself to have the Observer
which is really like feels like the
pause for me just to be able to like
take a second and not be in it but be
above it and watch it and be able to
slow down and recognize what's really
going on so like the title The the you
know it's a journey Beyond yourself so
what
what would you describe as the self Well
everybody's conscious they don't pay
attention to it but if they weren't
conscious they wouldn't know anything
right so right people say oh my thoughts
are driving me crazy I always say how do
you know
like I'm weird right no seriously how do
you know that your heart hurts how do
you know that your thoughts are driving
you crazy and eventually they'll look at
me and yell at me very angry because I'm
in here and I see it and I'll pronounce
to them and say well that's very deep
you're obviously in there you obviously
are aware that there are thoughts in
there you just don't step back and
notice that someone's noticing but
someone's always noticing you wouldn't
know what's happening all right and that
is how I Define the self it is the
conscious Observer that is aware there
are thoughts it's aware that their
emotions certainly aware of that
right like you say to me well when he
did this I felt so much love it but then
he slurped a soup I couldn't handle it
how do you know how do you know that's
going on in there because I'm cautious
the same way you know you're looking at
me because you're a conscious being that
Consciousness is who you are that never
changes you're always conscious you're
just conscious of different things
different kinds of thoughts different
kind of emotions different things
outside it's always the same
Consciousness so that's pretty far out
isn't it yeah well I want to take it
even further out so is that
Consciousness an overlay for the whole
thing for what you are on a fundamental
level meaning are is that Consciousness
existing and I'm presuming is that
Consciousness what exists in all the
different dimensions all the timelines
that you exist in in all potential
realities you're going mystical on me
like basically we start this way when
you were 10 years old did you ever look
in the mirror yeah okay you didn't look
like you look now Okay small he looked
different but wasn't you looking
it's it's you
like that Consciousness is there all the
time it's just aware of different egos
it's aware of different likes and
dislikes and personalities but you were
there you were there the whole time
right so we start there is that that is
what they call the soul that's what they
call the Atman they get all these weird
names I don't like oh the self okay I
like to just say you you in there hi
okay and now now the question becomes
what's what you ask which I don't
normally go there but what's the
relationship between your Consciousness
and my Consciousness well Consciousness
that's like saying if I stand on one
side of the ocean you sit on the other
side we're looking at the same ocean
okay Consciousness is a is an entity
isn't a Nate has a nature which is
awareness and your awareness is aware of
different things than mine but awareness
is awareness and that's where you were
going where awareness is all the same
every you know it's the most magical
thing in the whole universe oh awareness
right you can say all these things are
neat but if Noah is aware of them they
mean nothing
do we share do we share part of that
awareness together is that lacka is that
when you let when you when you get past
separateness then do we share that
awareness together
there is an ocean there is a universe of
undifferentiated awareness that is
looking down through your eyes through
my eyes through right through every
single that's the Oneness
that's that's what it wouldn't it be
nice for example and imagine all the
people understanding that there's a
commonality amongst all of us
we're all aware and we're aware of
different things
is this separateness innate to our Human
Experience or is that something that
we're meant to transcend
well you're deep are you okay
I don't even throw a race car driving no
well you know my agent described me the
most accurate way possible that I didn't
even realize and this is this is another
conversation another question we could
get into but people show us who we are
it's hard to see us but he would say he
would describe me to sponsors to
companies to give me money and promote
their products and he would say racing
is what she what she does but it's not
who she is well that that's everything I
teach right you go even deeper you're
not even your personality right not your
preferences you're the one that's aware
of those don't you change your mind
sometimes of course but it's still you
yes exactly you in there that oh maybe
this maybe that no yeah there's one
Consciousness being aware of all of that
so basically to me what I've learned is
that the most meaningful life is to grow
what does that mean to notice that
there's stuff going on inside you
there's not so much fun for you or
anybody else okay can you raise above
that can you change not much I don't
like to change that but change your seat
of awareness so I can look at this part
of me that you know just silly okay I
don't want I don't give that up all
right but if I suppress it then it
really becomes part of my personality so
you don't suppress things well if I
express it to let it out then I'm
dumping on somebody you know I don't
like what you said to me don't you talk
to me like that okay I get that well
what if I step back and say I am aware
that this is upset in here I'm aware
that this inner thing where I live my
house is it's got a little tornado going
on there all right can I just relax and
step back and be aware I'm not denying
that it's happening but it's not me I'm
known as looking at it and something
very magical happens if you do that
enough it releases the energy to go to a
higher level like we hold you know if
you get upset but you don't want to the
best you do is push it down right we
have that tendency with hands inside
don't we right with hands inside like no
push that aside all right which is a
form of suppression you can instead
learn but it takes time but you learn to
relax in the face of all that and what
you'll find is it's all Just Energy
being disturbed and if you give it room
it will go up instead of down or out it
will go up it's called transmutation the
energy transmutes and it could start as
anger but it comes up as love finishes
when it finishes passing through instead
of hitting you and your will in there
then it shoots out it actually has the
ability to go up and if you do that
enough times
you're ecstatic you're becoming static
literally the energy goes up all the
time not just when things are the way
you want them to be you just relax and
the energy feeds you from inside and
there's this this River if you will of a
flow of really beautiful energy that
feeds you day and night and that is the
purpose of Our Lives is to evolve we've
already evolve you know we have tails
and we got two arms and two legs and
fingers opposing thumbs we've evolved
pretty good outside all right good girl
you revolved pretty good outside but
what about inside yeah we can't handle
anything we're supposed to be the
highest species of the planet which is
called adaptability right but we're not
very adaptable inside are we right we're
very seriously pattern making machines
that's right what we like and what we
don't like and we're serious about that
and you better behave the way I want you
to or I'll you know you'll pay for it as
opposed to it's just a something that
came in something that you said or
something that I thought you said and I
don't have to be like that I can relax
and then I can come with Clarity and
deal with the situation from a higher
place and that to me is the purpose of
life it's to evolve inwardly are we here
to experience the separateness as part
of being human or are we meant to
transcend it it's that we're meant to
witness it and not let it become a part
of us everything is a part of you and
I'm sure you've seen that okay
especially as you've grown through the
years right there's all kinds of stuff
in there right all kinds of stuff in
there what do we want to feed and pay
attention to and build okay as we're
growing so the first thing you do is you
you look at your person well first thing
you do is you look at your body am I
eating reasonably you've already done
all that okay you go through that Basics
if I'm eating food that's making me sick
it's silly okay I better be strong
enough to be able to rise above the
tendency to you know eat junk and to
smoke and to drink too much and Etc et
cetera right if we don't do that it
defines our life yeah you understand
that the body will then Define our life
the illnesses and discomforts of the
body okay so let's say but notice it
took Will and it took the willingness to
rise above the tendencies that the
habits that the body has formed okay so
the question you said is even with
dealing with your body which you know
most of us have done pretty good with
that at this point all right and you
would be where you are in life if you
hadn't all right so basically you write
there you use word rise above it you
rise above these Primal Tendencies to to
eat and lust and just go crazy over
you know basic biological things all
right and so you rise above that but
then you have this ego inside that
develops patterns of what it likes and
what it doesn't like and who it likes
and who it doesn't like and how you're
going to treat me how you're not going
to treat me and I don't want to get I
don't want to get old I don't want to
look old I I love when people do that or
I don't I don't want to look old I want
to look like I look now what was your
best year is 23 then when they ask you
to go to a conference that's the picture
you send out there even though you're 80
or here right and so you develop this
ego inside a self-concept that says this
is who I am right well you can rise
above that and how you don't deny it you
don't suppress it you don't dislike it
you just say Where's that going to take
me like some people say I don't want to
die
well I'm sorry every single thing that
was ever born died it's a one-to-one
correlation it's amazing all right so we
did a statistical study it was a hundred
percent of everything was born died so
to say I don't want to die what a
ridiculous thing to do with your life
that's like disappointment well you'll
be uptight all the time you'll make
yourself sick just like the body things
if you don't take care of them if you
notice here take care of yourself
psychologically inwardly what I call
your inner being you're gonna make
yourself sick and then you'll have to go
out and compensate for that by doing
things that make you feel better I was
everybody says I need this in a
relationship I need this I need money I
need things I need education or what I'm
not okay
I'm not okay inside I'm not whole I'm
not complete all right and so basically
I need to get things outside to
compensate for what's wrong inside
because spirituality says and what I've
learned over 50 years of doing this this
thing is why are you not okay inside
you've learned how to have your body be
okay reasonably not always but
reasonably right why is it not
reasonably okay inside to where you feel
love all the time sure you can share it
with somebody but wouldn't it be nicer
not to need them to be a certain way for
you to feel loved but for you to feel
love and you share it you share it I'm
far more consistent it's it's cleaner
all right for both of them and you
and you realize that's true of
everything so there's a there's a state
inside of ourselves
where we have risen above we talk about
Primal biological well there's Primal or
basic psychological okay I need things
I'm not okay I feel insecure I need to
prove myself I need to be treated a
certain way I just over and over and
over you've built this self-concept of
how thing how I need to how things need
to be for me to be okay how's that
that's right right hasn't everyone done
that how do things we all we all do I
mean we all do at times or all the time
okay well since there's only one world
out there and every one of us has a
different idea how it should be I wonder
why there's so many wars and divorces
and everything else that's why right
it's inevitable okay and so you get to
the point where you realize I can do
better than this just like you can do
better than smoking or hurting your body
but but not taking care of it I can take
care of the inside better than
compensating and expecting the world to
make me be okay when I'm not okay and in
fact no no I'm not okay I I'm making
myself not okay
I don't know how many can love me I've
never really felt that real and I don't
trust and so on I hope somebody finds up
they can client shows up they can
overcome that
you're in there telling yourself you're
not worthy of love you made all your
mistakes in your life and so on oh I
wonder where my soulmate is how you
define your soulmate somehow the person
that when they show up in my life
overcome everything I did to screw
myself up
can you relate to that do you understand
that of course yeah relationships bring
it up the most okay and what what I call
the spirituality but that the
evolutionary the real evolution is why
can't I be whole and complete Within
Myself all right can I be that's the
first thing unless you're gonna find out
if you work on yourself is the only
reason you're not
is because your Consciousness is looking
at garbage it's looking at insecurities
looking at jealousy it's looking at need
it's looking at preferences looking at
desire it's looking at fear isn't it
because that's what it sees in there so
therefore you think you are fear and you
are insecure and no you're not you're
the Consciousness that's aware of these
things well what would happen if you
paid more attention to your
Consciousness your awareness of being
and that's what the great ones have
found you happen to be ecstatic you
happen to be the most beautiful thing in
the whole world you happen to be what
the Bible means when it says man was
creating the image of God
okay that there is this beautiful being
who's you your real self looking at
garbage not always garbage
it could be nice all right but it's very
conditional isn't it hey man there's a
lot of garbage in there I give you that
and it's conditional I'm okay people say
to me but I'm okay you're okay as long
as the wife's okay
goes to Harvard as long as they get days
as long as you get your raise don't you
have the corner corner of the thing as
long as you have your Ferrari whatever
it is what if those things are taken
away they look at me say why did you say
that why would you think of that right
it's conditional your state of being is
conditional upon the outside being a
certain way and of course it's not
always that way it's very rarely you
have to work you have to work hard to
make it that way right what what is it
that gives us that belief system that if
we get this when this happens what is
the mechanism where does that begin for
us where we associate with the ifs and
whens instead of the uh higher
Consciousness that is light is positive
energy
there was a social psychology and I'm
not a psychologist I never even took a
psychology course let's get that done
straight I was an economics major
very successful very successful
businessman that's right so the F
Skinner you may have heard of him or I
was a social psychologist and he made a
statement that mostly true but I always
qualified he said man is the sum of his
learned experiences
okay that's pretty true okay like if you
like somebody and you're feeling love
for them and a friend comes up and tells
you that you better go talk to Barbara
look what happened to her when she dated
him
instantaneously you feel differently
you know the sum of your learned
experiences if your friend then says oh
you see it's April Fool's first day I
was just kidding you then I go all right
so we are programmed by our outer
experiences
all right so a child who's watching TV
and they see a truck that he says this
truck will make you happy they go to the
parents
okay and guess what if they get the
truck for a very short period of time
they're happy
okay because they told themselves this
is what I need in order to be okay so
instead of asking why am I not okay well
I'm not okay you're asking what do I
need to be okay that's the major
difference of whether you're growing
inwardly or you're attached to
struggling externally is you think I can
only be okay if I get the things that I
got before
or similar you extrapolate right things
that made me had a relationship and
eighth grade and it was so beautiful and
she was redheaded okay my wife no that's
not true all right
he was redheaded and she left you know
her parents moved right and it was never
a bad experience in that relationship it
was just the most perfect relationship
you ever had right you understand now if
I'm grown up and I I go on a date and
shoot a red hat she redheaded I have a
pretense propensity toward being open
you just asked a question why do we
think we need these things all right
because we're not okay inside and we've
had experiences either you read a book
it'll tell you you need that to be okay
you watch a movie meet somebody you can
have a thought
if I had a Tesla
okay it used to be a Ferrari that's a
Tesla all right I I bet everyone would
be proud of me and I feel like I'm
helping the ecology and so all of a
sudden I'm not okay I'm going to get a
Tesla and if I get a Tesla oh my God for
a while how am I doing wonderful so
that's how you develop your preferences
is through programming you get
programmed by your past experiences
do you think the more you get what you
think will make you happy
do you think the more you get those
things actually it programs you to be
less happy because on the other side of
it is essentially not the answer the
answer is an inside job beyond the thing
that you think you should be getting to
make you happy is that
part of like I'm just thinking about
super successful wealthy people that
have children and they probably get tons
of things that they want and if we're
just sort of like
being broad-based they tend to be
unhappy or they don't have they're not
as they're not as fulfilled
is that pointing in the direction of
don't always fulfill those desires that
you think will make you happy
well first of all as an economist
there's a law of diminishing returns
economics but I remember more of being
spiritual okay the more you guess
something the less you want it
and that includes relationships you
start getting used to each other you
start what used to turn you on right I
need something new right or wrong I mean
I always okay plead the fifth so
basically there is a law of diminishing
returns now you may stay together for
the kids but that's not the same as the
honeymoon phase that took place okay
that first kiss somehow is a magic to it
the 12th sixth thousandth all right
somehow it doesn't do the same things
all right right you start waking up and
realizing it doesn't work it works short
term to say I want something and then
get it that absolutely brings you it
opens you that's the key open I open
because I went to Hawaii I opened
because I got this car open because of
this I opened because he said he loved
me oh my God right what you felt was
inside of you by opening but I closed
when he said yeah but I'm not ready to
get married for five years and you gotta
wait okay
that well that's opening and closing
you're doing that inside yourself and so
ultimately you get down to the point
where you realize either I'm going to
spend my life trying to have experiences
that open me so that I can feel good
feel high Feel Love or I'm going to find
out why I close
[Applause]
all the time
and you say well I can't I can't because
it's not the way I want but if you
worked with that but if you learn to
raise yourself to I people sometimes say
to me I mean you say we shouldn't have
preferences that's impossible no you can
have I'll give you one preference that
you're absolutely allowed to have Danica
I prefer that everybody be the way it is
I get one that's your preference I
prefer that everything be the way it is
I prefer that the experience I'm having
is the experience I'm having that's my
base that's like a baseline belief for
people if you right I'm I'm saying if
you were to say that inside yourself
even have swiss and walk the face of the
Earth because you just said however it
is that how I want it to be oh so
everything's great everything you're
always ecstatic everything's perfect
it's always perfect and so you sit there
and say but but I don't feel that way
that's lying to myself no you've been
programmed to not like someone who
slurped soup you could have been
programmed that your Uncle George or
soup and he was wonderful and you loved
him to pieces and now you're going to
date and somebody slurped soup he said
oh my God his first soup and your heart
melts you understand that there's
nothing intrinsic about the action it's
your preference system that you got
programmed with inside and so you
eventually catch on wouldn't I be better
off here I know someone that read
literally read to the cavernous in their
kitchen six not that's exaggerated three
to four times wow we're not exactly the
color of what she expected them to be
right and they kept changing them right
wouldn't it be nicer to say you know
what that's not what I thought it would
be but I like it better right what if
you always said that wow
I mean that's a transformation so what
do we do how do we Bypass or how do we
get Beyond this
reptilian primitive protective brain of
keeping things the same and wanting to
repeat these patterns how do we how do
we I know one of the big things is is is
letting things go when they come in it's
it's allowing it to flow through you
instead of gets stuck in you because
then it becomes part of your patterning
so what is guide us through how we do
that how do people not piss me off no I
don't you read the antenna Soul yes did
you ever see my new book I have not read
living untethered no living under
because you just said it okay maybe you
don't need to read it because sure I do
okay that is exactly correct you first
start with saying this is not about
pronunciation it's not about not doing
things it's not about not being happy
it's not about giving up the world all
right it's just like it's not about
giving up food if you eat what makes you
healthy instead of what makes you sick
you don't give up food you never know
ounce right you just did better you
intelligently made decisions that made
you broke it's the same thing inside you
sit there and say like for example and
it's funny I use example all the time
don't don't accuse me of doing it just
because you're here you're driving down
the road on a single line lane highway
right and you're in a rush always and
there's a person in front of you driving
10 miles an hour below the speed limit
how are you doing oh my God I'm anxious
okay okay and judging and judging well
of course you're driving yourself crazy
right your mind is going crazy to you
but totally totally in control for me
okay that's okay so when you're pulling
out to see if you can pass I mean you're
you're not comfortable you understand
that you're not comfortable right but
the reality of the fact is it's not
helping if you're stuck behind this car
driving 10 miles an hour all you've done
is make yourself neurotic it did not
change anything the cost benefit
analysis as a business person the cost
is 100 the benefits zero
to make yourself look tight about that
or okay we'll start with that one so
what do you do you consciously look and
say this is a part of my being it's
there I have this anxiety and you know
et cetera and judgment and
Neurosis okay and basically I would like
to learn to work with it not to suppress
it not to deny it right to work with it
because it doesn't make sense it's just
like eating junk food it makes you sick
this is eating junk thoughts and junk
emotions I mean there's nothing to do
about it you'll wait me two blocks later
he turns to the right and then you drive
it was worth that it was worth that let
me ruined your day okay and that's what
I call in the new book I call it
low-hanging fruit
low-hanging fruit is that which is as
follows right the moment in front of you
is not bothering you you're bothering
yourself about the moment in front of
you facts can you relate to that okay
yes and if you're doing it and there's
no benefit no benefit it's not going to
change anything
then you need to learn to not do that
because that's not rational it is making
you so sick but how do you learn not to
do it you make a game out of like a
video game okay you look at it and you
sit there and say okay look at this
thing
relax
what relax now some people when I say to
think you're trying to make your
Neurosis or your anxiety relax no
anxiety doesn't know how to relax
anxiety is anxious you're saying that
this is nature right it's all jumpy and
stuff like that right but you who's
noticing it you has the hands in there
you can relax you can sit there and say
okay fine just relax and lean away from
the noise just go to that place okay
that's like a Zone like what I'm saying
athletes talk about being in the zone
right there's a Zone inside if you relax
behind that noise there's a peace back
there there's a there's a quiet doesn't
be a big spiritual experience but it's a
heck of a lot nicer to hang out with
anxiety yeah it's the Observer it's what
it feels like you're the Observer and
you relax and if you do that over time
not immediately but over time you will
find that that which was making you
anxious the Neurosis downstairs oh my
God my boss is going man I told him I'd
be there I'm going to be late you can be
just as late anyways sorry it's not
going to change the thing you look at
that and you realize I'm okay I'm okay
it doesn't do any good to show up
neurotic okay so you let go and as you
let go you'll notice amazing thing that
energy that was was all weird because
you didn't touch it it changed it was
able to come up all right or you start
using affirmation right you sit there
and say oh come on this is probably a an
older person like my grandmother my
grandma I do yes yes
that's right they get to drive and I
should not be talking at them or
bothering them or even sending them bad
vibes maybe they should not be driving
any faster well and the point is it's a
latter part of their life and at least
they get to go some places or something
it means a lot more to them than this
Neurosis means to me and you feel like
you're giving something instead of
demanding and taking you can change
yourself it's not about suppressing it's
not about denying it's about raising you
raise yourself pausing almost feels like
it generates compassion a little bit
what you'll find out is you back there
are the most beautiful thing in the
whole universe you are filled with love
you're filled with compassion you're
filled with inspiration you're filled
with Michael shock the energy the spirit
energy quote whatever you want filled
with it all the time but you're busy
looking down at this garbage and so you
learn to raise yourself the other
example that I like to use because I'm
very much into
being brought and seeing the whole
universe instead of just your little
tiny world right is let's say it's hot
out nowadays we have global warming
we're hot okay it's very hot out you're
standing there and you have to go from
one place to another and you're actually
outside with no air conditioning isn't
that terrible and as you're walking
you're complaining oh my God it's so
freaking hot and I'm sweating I don't
want to sweat I don't like this sort of
thing and I always have to be so hot
what's wrong with these people Bubba
okay well that doesn't help anything it
doesn't make it cooler it doesn't do a
single thing it's the same thing like
the car but what if you sat there I know
I trained Mickey this I trained Michael
this way all right as I sit there and I
look and I say how did it get hot be
quiet how did it get hot what do you
mean why is it hot
well because there's a son out there you
mean there's a star 93 billion miles
away and you're it's hot it's so hot
that you feel is he here I'm in
Gainesville Florida Miami is about 300
miles away I asked them how big would a
fire have to be in Miami for you to
steal it in Gainesville if the whole
town caught fire you would not even know
what happened that thing's 93 million
it's 93 million miles away
and you can feel the star shine okay you
can feel is that neat and all of a
sudden it's like imagine me that's right
yeah I can feel a star the stars are
neat things right and you start working
with yourself that way and it works you
raise yourself
what get curious
yeah use the higher part of your mind
yes your intellect to raise above this
garbage ah work with the Mind work with
the ego work with the mind
so one thing that I have thought many
times that I'm curious about your
opinion on a perspective
is whether or not anyone's actually
really wrong no what we are the sum our
minds our egos our preferences are the
sum of our learned experiences okay and
every single person has had different
experiences yes one of the things I try
to teach people is okay at a given
moment you're having an experience right
okay we're having experience okay and
before you had an experience so there's
that experience of that moment how many
experiences are you missing
700 billion zillion quillion every
single moment yes right somebody else is
being programmed with those experiences
you're being programmed with this
experience then the next moment is
another experience another no one ever
has ever had the same experience as you
not need leave with that no one has ever
had it and no one ever will you're the
most unique thing in the universe and so
is everybody else but since we're the
sum of our learned experiences or at
least our psyche is we're not the
Consciousness is not we are watching the
sum of our learned experiences The
Observer watches right so that's where I
take it take a pick a bone with Skinner
right it's not that man just the Summer
Long experiences man the Consciousness
the awareness of being but the psyche
they look at which is what he was
talking about is the cellular
experiences so everybody's a summer
learned experiences and everyone had
different experiences so you're
absolutely right how can they be wrong
you think you're right you think you're
right she said don't dare do that I
can't believe you did that that was so
wrong right because based on your
experiences that's out of the question
on somebody else's experience they don't
know what you're talking about that's
why this whole politics stuff is so
stupid right it's it's like they're I
they don't understand they're just
expressing the southern learned
experiences and if you had a different
experience one different experience you
would have a different opinion right
right or wrong right I tell I tell a
story for one hour at a time it's a very
powerful story I tell a story that
there's two kids seven to eight years
old in the back of the station wagon and
the parents are driving to go on a
vacation and they're playing you know I
spy that kind of a game back there
playing around and so the sister who's a
year older says I spy and Oak Tree to
the right and the little boy turns
around and at that exact moment there
was a terrible accident with body parts
and blood and he's traumatized for life
okay they can't even bring him back and
never get into a car he can't do
anything could that happen right what if
she had said oh look over here
his whole life's changed I don't accept
that
that's that's ridiculous that's not fair
that's out of the question you
understand that as your entire life was
based on one random moment yeah they
look somewheres or some okay and so you
but that is how it is we're programmed
with itself and so anyone that has gone
through the their lifetime experiences
they think they're right they think this
is how can they think otherwise
you're saying that they're programming
with that yeah okay so or I don't know
any sensitive political subjects but any
subject you take where there's two sides
it's because somebody had enough
experiences yeah on this side so they
say I know what I'm talking about I had
a sister who went through that right
this person well I had a sister and she
okay and if you had different
experiences it takes real humility to
admit that if you had different
experiences you would see it differently
yeah so yes you're right that from a
personal point of view everybody thinks
they're right and nobody's right right
because they just have these I I call
those experiences
statistically insignificant
all right and it was the fact that you
picked up one point out of the billions
that existed at that moment and that's
all you're ever getting that as we call
statistically insignificant data
a wise person laosue he said or wise
being he said A wise man never argues
for what purpose
it's not that they don't try to raise
the world but you're not fighting with
it because you understand with
compassion I understand how you see it
that way I don't see it that way but I
understand how you see it that way
because you had different experiences
now how can we get along
if everyone was that humble and everyone
was that open and they respected that's
called respect right and we we could
find a way to do much better than we're
doing a good way
um
for sure
why is it so hard to see ourselves
because in those in that example of some
somebody doing something and them being
wrong
it's hard to see that we've been
programmed a certain way
why is there this sort of
conundrum where or this challenge of
being a human where we really can't see
ourselves the saying you know we don't
see things as they are we see things as
we are but yet we can't see ourselves we
don't understand in that interaction
when somebody does something like they
drive slow on the road it's because I am
crazy and neurotic about driving fast
like why can't I see that instead why do
I see them as the problem this to me is
like one of the sort of big challenges
and Mysteries of being a human is this
inability to really have that
self-reflection you you are distracted
by that which is the loudest whatever it
is if there's a big noise outside and
we're having a conversation you're not
paying attention to me anymore you're
paying attention to the noise if you
drop a hammer on your toe right you're
not paying attention to the rest of your
body silly I don't know why it puts
attention there it's important rehearse
the most but that's true okay you have
thoughts that are more powerful because
they're charged you had experience in
the past you had a divorce 20 years ago
and all of a sudden you hear the
person's name it's not the same person
but you hear the name all of a sudden
you're lost so you get distracted by
that which is most pulling on your
Consciousness into straps your
Consciousness that's your answer and
that's why people can't come back here
right because they get pulled back down
into the heartache into the heart love
the same right I'm madly love with
somebody I can't stand them oh in other
words your heart has changed and you got
sucked into it
so is you said the charge and I want to
talk about energy chakras because you
say you come back down or you need to go
up to transcend Beyond something that an
event happens and they get stored that's
right lower so essentially you come out
of your higher chakras and you come down
into this primitive lower chakras in the
first second third and that's where you
get stuck and so it's stuck energy am I
am I gathering information right you
will love my new book this is this is
exactly what new book talks about why do
you think I love this book okay so so
basically
the the new book literally says what is
mine and how did it get the way it is
all right and it starts with the Zen
concept of empty mind there's nothing in
there it's like a computer that's so
powerful because there's no software
doesn't mean it's stupid right it's just
not right now doing anything it's not
creating thoughts all right then what
happens the world comes in through your
senses because that's what it does right
and it builds patterns in your mind yeah
right that's what's happening you're
seeing inside all right well if those
patterns are normal a tree a car or this
or that they just go right through yeah
I always tell my people you're already
99 enlightened 99 of every single thing
that comes into your senses makes it
right through
yeah I mean sure I mean I love the
analogy in the book that you use about
the I think it's maybe a blue car I
think it's a blue car and if you see a
blue car go down the road it means
nothing to someone but if your
ex-boyfriend had a blue car if you see
the blue car all of a sudden bam that
blue car means something that's right
how many cars do you see go by that mean
nothing that's right that's right 99
these leaves grass everything makes it
through then they don't experience it
you just experience it read it out right
yeah it comes in which is a group which
is good news but then what happens is
something comes in like a rattlesnake
and it's scary yeah it is naturally
scary I've seen coiled rattlesnakes I
live in the woods around the country
right and they are scary all right and
you're going to get this this vibration
like that it's not comfortable okay fine
but then it crawled away does that
discomfort crawl away no because you
won't let it pass through you use those
hands and they're saying no I don't want
to have this experience I don't like
that I had the experience probably you
did have the experience
programming has told you rattlesnakes
are dangerous I can even even if I
didn't ever have that programming it
sends off Vibes that are meant to scare
you oh the nature of a rattlesnake is
get away from me okay it comes in but
when it crawls away it could pass
through doesn't mean you didn't learn
but it passed through but no I was so
uncomfortable that I don't want to have
had the experience pay attention to that
right I literally don't want to have had
it so it happened outside but I don't
have to let it pass all the way inside I
can suppress it there's Freud I can push
away the event inside and it goes down
your subconscious and then bees the way
you talked earlier that we have all this
stuff stored in there have we not made a
collection of every bad experience we
ever had yeah for sure we have if you
make a collection of everything that
ever disturbs you you're going to be
disturbed
they were so silly we're supposed to be
simple and yet so hard uh it's so
ridiculous all right so we do that and
we it's almost instinctual like if I
throw a ball at you you throw your hands
up that's what we do inside we use those
inner hands no no I don't have this and
we push it away and only because you're
being so high I'll give you the other
side you meet somebody and they're
beautiful you see a butterfly comes and
lands on your arm as I use in the book
that's a nice experience let's push that
one away I can't wait for that day I
dream about that when I'm hiking I'm
like just land on it when the butterfly
flies away we don't like that we want it
to stay there so we can't cling to the
butterfly because it flew away but we
can cling to the experience
we can keep the experience inside so
that we miss every other experience
because the busy thinking about the
butterfly and busy wanting the butterfly
to happen you understand that these are
both positive and negative subscribers
so you push away the negative ones you
cling to the positive one and you now
that's where your personality came from
you scored this these events but not all
events you only stored the powerful ones
you understand that that's what he said
the powerful weather they're good or bad
that's exactly right they just reach a
threshold and they are now programmed
and you store them and now your entire
personality is built around that you sit
there and say where do I want to live
where there's no rattlesnakes where
where how can I see the butterfly again
those are your likes and dislikes and
you're like people I you meet a person
that you love them to Pieces until you
find any collects rattlesnakes
yeah right so is it equally dangerous to
Value both of them and store both of
them I I I don't people aren't ready to
talk at this absolute level of train of
non-duality and Transcendence so I only
threw that in because you've been asking
us High questions right because it does
mess you up okay if you go into a
restaurant have a beautiful experience
the music is perfect the menu is perfect
the people they are sitting the distance
away is just right the right number of
people in there right and say I want to
go back I want to go back to laws where
the restaurant was right you are going
to be disappointed that's exactly right
that's what I was thinking of I was
thinking about having an experience that
you loved going on a trip that you love
and then I've done this before where you
try and recreate it because you're like
this was amazing and and exactly what
you said happens you're I would say
always disappointed you will always be
and if you bring friends with you wait
till you see this right then you're
embarrassed
it became a bad experience became a
negative experience right so the answer
the answer is people always ask me do
can I really not enjoy positive
experiences I said you've got so many
negative ones just work on that don't
worry about the rest we'll go that
that's graduate school
the positives are nothing at this point
in time I wish that was your problem
okay there's too many positive thoughts
in there but why do you have all these
Nate whites why naturally people say to
me I practice positive thinking I'm
terrible you know I always say to that
person why
and that is positive thinking but why do
why do you practice the problem with
thinking well because I don't what
happens if you don't it's negative yeah
why why is it that way this book gets
into that the whole Foundation of what
you built in there is trying to release
all the time just like it comes up in
your dreams it comes up all day and you
and all you remember all this stuff that
bothers you and everything stimulates
your stuff yeah okay and that's why it's
the way it is in there so what's the
answer get that stuff out and you said
that earlier I was very proud of you
right that you got this stuff in there
you store all this stuff in there then
it becomes how do you do that because if
you get that stuff out you're filled
with love all the time there's an
underlying energy that is your natural
being when things happen that you like
you open and you feel that Natural
Energy
okay and you can have that all the time
if you just get rid of all this garbage
that's in there and it you know there's
a Freud said it it's funny that it is
that what you stored in there became
your psychology that's what psychology
is founded on is that you stored all
this garbage in there and so now it's
coming back up and you have to learn to
code well spirituality doesn't say you
need to learn to cope he says get it out
but but I can't that's like a drug
addict saying I can't stop doing drugs
it's difficult but people have gone
through withdrawal haven't they so it is
not true that you can't
you have to want to enough and you have
to be guided and work with different
tools but you can get your life back
just because you got hooked up on heroin
or something right you can go through
the withdrawal this is a form of
withdrawal is withdraw from from the
garbage that I wasn't able to handle
when I was five my parents got divorced
I couldn't handle it now I don't ever
want to get married I don't want to do
that to my kids I don't know they're
going to have kids because I got hurt so
people do that
like I said why don't they step back
because it's so powerful it captures
their Consciousness how's this they
aren't able to step back for the same
reason that a drug addict keeps trying
to have drugs because the pool is so
strong
you understand that the pool of the fear
the full of the anxiety so you learn to
little by little by practicing a piano
first time you sit down on the piano you
can't play well don't try to play
Beethoven right away or you'll get up
and you'll be disappointed you do these
things called scales or tennis or any
any sport you start from the beginning
yeah that's what you do here don't try
to get rid of the divorced husband that
you had all these fights with don't do
that don't touch that right deal with
the heat deal with the car in front of
you deal with these little low-hanging
fruits that you do bother yourself about
you don't realize that you couldn't do I
play in the scales you can develop the
ability to let go you develop it there's
nobody can't say to me I'm not the kind
of person that can let go so I suffer
well you can learn
and then you build muscle you build
inner not not muscle to suppress right
you know tell me let's say your heart
hurts and somebody hurts you but you're
you're a very strong lady you're a very
strong person right uh I'm not gonna put
up with that push it away right push it
away I can deal with this and push it
away it takes more strength to Let It Go
it takes a stronger person to handle the
pain oh yeah and the disturbance and
breathe and say okay before I say one
word I'm letting this go because I don't
want to be like this and that then I can
deal with it
that's more strength isn't it that's a
stronger person it makes me feel the
word vulnerability and that you know
releasing something carrying through the
emotion letting it flow through you
somatically verbally whatever
um energetically is a sign of of
strength as opposed to weakness
it's it's amazing how much it takes for
you if your heart hurts because somebody
disappointed you all right to
rationalize it forgive them do whatever
I can do to not have to deal with that
pain is very different than saying I
want to be able to handle this then I'll
deal with the situation it's not that
would deal with the situation but I
don't want to deal with the situation
because I can't handle it
you understand that and people say that
I can't handle this they can't handle it
right they fail they they make a mess
right you're always better off saying I
can handle this oh that's a great Mantra
I that that's the March I told Oprah
when we had a talk I can handle this I
don't give mantras I'm not a guru or
anything right but basically that's a
very high mantra if you had that going
on all the time I can handle this I can
handle this I can handle this he forgot
the anniversary I can handle that we've
been married five years I'll deal with
it but I'm not going to deal with it as
hurt as insulted as he doesn't love me
no that's not being able to handle a
moment in life I can handle it and so
what do you do you learn it's always
about relaxing it's like yoga it's about
relaxing
you relax into it you relax you don't
get into it you relax behind it keep
your hands to yourself and let it work
its way through but it hurts more of
course it does it's coming closer to you
you understand that the whole event the
whole energy comes more up in your heart
to get through your throat it's tough to
rationalize Let It Go that's right and
you let it go and once you can do that
with a little stuff you'll find that you
can do it with the medium stuff okay and
it wouldn't even the medium stuff will
look like little stuff just like when
you start playing the scales you can
play Twinkle Twinkle
and then you can play Beethoven right as
you practice and practice that goes for
like listen you're a driver you're an
athlete athletes have to practice you
practice raising yourself you practice
Letting Go you practice saying I don't
want this stuff in here you're a
beautiful successful person right you
don't want that stuff in there yeah you
understand that you don't want it in
there I don't care what it is so how
about how much justifiable it is right I
don't care you're going to get a Blog
and everyone will agree with you if that
happened to me I no no no those are not
your friends
understand that they're feeding your
weaknesses and so you basically work
with yourself you keep letting go and
you're going to get stronger and
stronger but that that kind of strength
the strength to stay centered all the
time and then eventually you'll get to a
point where some big stuff will come up
and and I want to see your eyes when
what you say about the big stuff is come
on
come on up you're welcome in here I
don't want that down there I will go
through anything and that's when you
start to get high that's going to start
to reach those points they talk about
energy just pouring through you just get
intoxicated all the time for no reason
yeah
ecstatic ecstatic well when you say I
can handle this then it allows you that
pause then it allows you to get into a
place of compassion where you get
curious and think how could this be and
you realize nobody's ever wrong they're
just doing the best from their level of
Consciousness and experience
but what happens in Life or what feels
like happens is
saying new love of devil
as you continue on your journey yes you
get a new level very good
so do those levels ever end and by
levels for those that are confused and
following along is that you heal
some aspect of yourself or you reconcile
it or you learn to get past it but then
you dive deeper and you go along your
life you might be doing just fine and
then all of a sudden boom you found
yourself caught up again you find
yourself triggered you find yourself
depressed you find yourself anxious you
find yourself caught again and you're
not necessarily dealing with the old
problems you're dealing with new ones
but new level of that problem or or
others so is that your is that part also
of being human is this continuous
excavation and
getting to like do we get there the
ultimate question is what do we get to
and what are their thoughts around this
new level new Devil and this continuing
process of growing why why keep in the
work right so the new book is really
it's uncanny just how ready you offer
that a book because you just keep
teaching that's all right is
your natural state
is ecstatic in a natural state in in the
uh yogic tradition right that we have
something called Sachin have you ever
heard that sucks
internal conscious ecstasy that's your
natural state okay why am I not
experiencing that because I've put all
this stuff on here if it's beautiful out
but I close the blinds why is it dark in
here sure hello can you close the blocks
right so you shove all this stuff that
we've been talking about all the
suppressed stuff that resist this stuff
on top of your beauty on top of your
pure energy right so as you thin it out
I'll make statement it's always trying
to push up the energy is always it will
never stop it's it's natural state it's
to flow up but you got stuff in the way
okay so it's TR like I use the example
the Hoover Dam is a very big thing
blocking the Colorado River do you know
the Colorado River never stopped trying
to get past that Dam and it never will
stop yeah right yeah that's why they
have to keep fixing it it was always
trying to do its natural flow that's
what this is like inside the spirit flow
the Shakti flow all right it's always
trying to flow up and it'll push your
stuff out so when you say you know
different layers come up later right
yeah you can't handle the Deep layers so
it'll push up it'll push up which you
can start to handle but then you push it
back down you do it all the time push it
back down right right no I I'm not all
right I'll be all right two days later
for now just leave me alone right push
it back down right instead you start
saying okay I'm going to learn how to
handle this stuff then the next stuff
comes up why because it's like a stack a
computer stack all right it it just
comes up and then the next step comes up
because that's what's there and then
eventually really big stuff gets pushed
up that's a blessing that's a blessing
that's working with this stuff is the
purpose of your life it's the meaning of
your life now you asked me which I will
not normally talk about what you asked
is okay where does it end is there an
end okay well certainly I ain't there
okay all right but there are great
Masters real great Masters that have
existed on this plane that have taught
us what it means to reach the ultimate
all right so you work your way up you're
going through talk about chakras I don't
talk about those but yes you're working
away through the chakras and you're
cleansing right each one of those
centers is a Transformer that when you
when the energy can make it past the
first it has more power and that can
push through the second they can push
through the third they can push through
the fourth and when you can handle your
heart was really important you can
handle you know you talk about
compassion so you're in a relationship
with somebody they're hard for people
for these humans I don't you know you're
not human
you're not human you have a human that
you deal with you understand that but
your spirit you know you're a very high
being and you're in a relationship and
something happens that hurts your heart
you generally leave a relationship or at
least it hurts the relationship
tremendously and it's hard to ever get
it back at that level because you hold
that in there you basically suppressed
it they will reach the state where you
sit there and say well you've been
saying which is that person is different
than me who how do I know what they
meant by what they said their father
used to talk to them like that it didn't
mean anything but if no one ever talked
to me like that in my life well that's
your problem not theirs okay and you
start taking it that way to realize my
job is to let go of me so that
everything fits inside of me and you
keep letting go and letting go and
pretty soon it doesn't stop flowing then
it goes higher up and higher up and then
what happens is again I know what I'm
talking about this the energy is so
strong that flow is so strong inside and
it's intoxicating it's just beautiful
you can still work out here but how you
work out here by expressing that in your
work right so you're driving the car and
you're just focused and you're there or
you're doing work and all I don't care
if you're an assembly line you're just
putting your whole heart and soul into
what you're doing you're expressing the
beauty of your being
hear me ultimately when you go to work
you should not care about getting paid
if you're really high and you really got
there you can't believe they're giving
you money for you to go and express the
beauty of your being right in whatever
you're doing that's a high being and you
keep letting go and eventually the
energy is so beautiful that it starts to
pull you into it
it starts to take that which you see is
you and you start saying what am I doing
this energy is so beautiful nothing
ramdas once said you get to the point
where nothing can can come in from the
outside that is as beautiful as what's
already going on inside oh yeah okay
that's this energy flow and it's going
on and so you start getting pulled back
into it and you start realizing oh my
God
can I let go what would it be if I let
if I let go of me there's someone you
know real well who's talked about that
he said you must die to be reborn
that's the real dying right the ego or
of the dying of what are you dying of
the ego you're dying of what you thought
you needed what you want your
preferences because this this love this
beauty and Spirits that's flowing is so
strong you you just you're being called
into it you want to drop into it and so
now you get to where the great the great
Masters all right said if you were to
let go there's a great being great great
Master called mayor Baba who have you
ever heard of them but mayor Obama said
the first time he went into that state
it was like his Consciousness had been a
drop of water looking down at himself
right he let go and the drop fell into
the ocean
his dropper order falls into the ocean
find it you can't all right it merged
and that the word yoga means Union uh
emerging with the higher self and the
Earth with God call it what you want
right virgin with the infinite merging
with you know yeah and now you're
talking really high stuff you know
that's yeah I said like that's true
Enlightenment that's someone Buddha
reached that state crisis in that state
you know it's just basically you're
you're not you gave up on your
individual self and then you bring down
all that beauty and all that light but
you can still see the world so you're
still interacting and so on but just
being energy and being essentially a
light conduit of sorts
um I think about I think about things
kind of in a bit of a practical rational
sense but I think about our chakras and
I think about the dimensions and I think
about evolving and I think
that as we transition from this third
fourth into fifth density that we're
coming from these lower chakras we need
to open our heart to go up and then I
also think about the stories about these
um very Spiritual Beings that
um achieve What's called the rainbow
body
and I think about all the colors and how
the colors and the sounds and the
chakras and the dimensions like all
overlap
yes and so is that essentially the
final potential destination is that you
from what I understand the rainbow body
is when you essentially
evaporate from this body as a human
being
and you there's there's less left of you
even and you kind of do it in this other
state of being
consciously and awake you're awake
essentially but you you become less
actual physical being that you are and
you transcend and that's your passing
does any of that make sense does that
any of that spark any thoughts or I am a
very grounded spiritual person not all
Spiritual Beings are ground I'm very
grounded I I like science right I I all
of it right so I don't get very heavy
into the mystical stuff okay I know it's
true so the way I would look at what you
said is you have an aura okay and you
feel People's Energy you get around them
if they've been fighting they can look
at another one you feel it right so that
is a what we'll call your astral or oral
body it's just your energy body it
emanates from you based upon what your
energy is doing inside energy and
radiates it radiates and a lot of
people's ores are very dark because
that's what they have going on in their
heart because I am going on inside and
some of them are very very open right
and then as you let go of yourself
inside we've been talking about that as
you let go of the garbage inside and the
and the energy the light starts to flow
inside your aura gets wider and and
wider and larger and more beautiful it
gets more the colors are emanating they
don't have dark Reds which is anger they
don't have greens versus jealousy right
you've let go of a lot of this stuff and
so your energy body that you're
emanating and when you just call the
Rainbow I never heard that term but I
can relate to it I understand all right
then basically when there's nothing in
there personal
okay all that's flowing in there is
spirit all that's flowing in there are
Shakti right yeah it emanates I've I've
seen somebody paint a picture of what a
psychics is right and there's just
radiations of all the beautiful colors
so big coming up I have been in the
present I don't talk about it but I've
been in the presence of a very very high
being numerous times but I've been in
the presence of a being that in a large
room where there's thousand people okay
and come in the back of that room I
could not walk toward that person
the the magnetic field of what was
emanating from that being was that large
and as I walked closer and closer to
them it was just ecstatic it was just
doesn't always happen right I was open
enough at that time but that's what you
mean by the rainbow body right that a
very high being is emanating that light
emanating that that stuff and it doesn't
their physical body can still be there
they don't have to leave the body it
doesn't have to be death right it's just
they died in in the Christian sense
right you died to be reborn you let go
of yourself your personal self in order
to to merge into your spiritual self all
the Traditions are the same I don't like
to get into religion and stuff because
it just becomes Dogma right just because
all the rules and stuff like divisive
yeah but but but the high beings right
there I think Francis was a high being
Christ was the highest they come Buddha
was phenomenal but what they did with it
I don't want to discuss all right but
it's good to understand that you're
capable of all that you're capable and
of evolving to that point and that is
what we started talking about you're
asking me are we evolving you're
evolving and how high can we get merge
the whole universe your
you are the greatest thing to walk the
face of the Earth what is the next
reality look like for us as humans when
we evolve to the next level it's what
it's supposed to be it's like all right
basically
don't even go to that level just come to
a level where people woke up enough to
realize what you where you are which is
just what you said right that we're all
different and of course it looks like
there's right and wrong because we're
all programmed differently let's get
above that and they can't they're saying
that they're completely caught on their
egos the eye all right but if we just
raise above that even just above that we
can sit there on the table together and
say I understand how you see it the way
you do I understand I understand you I I
always talk about guns so we take that
one it's neutral up I understand that
you grew up in a culture and they had
guns and they're hunting and they have
all this and it means a lot to you right
and they say to you I understand that
people are being killed and that this is
a difficult situation what a way to sit
down and start a damn conversation okay
so what would dissolve if we get to that
point where we can get above that what
institutions
and patterns and realities that we live
in now what what do you see dissolving
in that space well let me ask you this
right now people are not okay they're
not okay they're suffering inside right
because all that stuff right okay so
they're trying to do things outside that
will make them feel better and that I
did third years of prison work at Max
security prison I used to go and teach
the stuff they robbed they've killed
they've hurt they've done things why
because they're not okay if you are
filled with love and beauty inside you
do not Rob because you don't need
anything you do not kill because nothing
bothers you enough to do such a thing
imagine if we raised human human
consciousness up to that level we
wouldn't need all laws we didn't need
all the structures naturally but we do
now right I mean I I wouldn't even need
money because you just give what you
could it's like you don't need anything
you're whole within yourself the basic
needs sure so you want to share it's
your natural way of being they only feel
like you know at some point you don't
even think you're giving because it has
no meaning to you you understand if
you're full and you have tons of food
and someone's starving
it doesn't hurt you it means nothing
just give them something but you don't
think you're giving you say here take
something
right so that all the concepts change
everything changes as as Evolution takes
place but how do you how does one do
that and my experience is all you can be
responsible for is yourself your
starting position is right you have to
evolve with the different situations
that are presented to you and my
experiences if you do that
the rest will happen the people around
you will be raised naturally understand
that like if you bring anger into a
situation imagine a household or always
fighting if all of a sudden somebody's
not and somebody's bringing
understanding and love that's all they
have to do it will change things
right but you you can't sit there and
say I won't change until everybody else
does
not going to protect myself that doesn't
work
right so that you're asking you like
there's no surprise you I said big
things all right it's like can it be
better of course it could be better but
it requires that everybody work on
themselves
because well they're not working on
themselves they're working on everybody
else they're just trying to manipulate
there's this interesting Dynamic where I
feel like there's there's so many
teachers and and and people that or
activists
um
promoters lobbyers all these things and
they're trying to get people to do
things or to think a certain way and
it's always an inside job it's like a
you know I have like imagine a parent
that has a child who has an addiction
you can't make them stop they have to
want to stop so really this conversation
any other one that I have or any of the
work it's like all you can do is try and
Inspire somebody to do the inside job
that's the only way it works so
counter-intuitively it's almost like you
want to go out into the world and help
but it's really actually when you fix
your world that that's what we all have
to do but it's like there's a level of
surrender in that I feel like but that's
the other that's why other book that you
didn't read really would blow you away I
have it I have it yeah the surrender
experiment I do have the surrender
experience definitely when you when you
finish reading that because it changes
all the way through and you're going to
get a lot from that so the answer is you
are completely right that's all you can
do right is do the best that you can do
on you all right otherwise you're
keeping yourself upset because other
people are not working on themselves
you can't do that that's not what it's
about and as you raise yourself that's
my experience that's just my experience
as you raise yourself it's amazing what
ends up happening right I mean three
million people over three almost four
million people have read the
surroundings the surrender assuming they
don't have a soul right I had no
intention I never thought of it or
anything like that I just wrote down
what I wanted had something to say I
wrote it down right it's been published
from 34 languages and all this and I
just sitting there saying oh
oh cause there's an emanation of light
and a nation of of Hope and emanation of
inspiration that comes from someone who
who's doing that work you know that has
worked on themselves and sees that
there's something higher in there I
don't go out I I rarely do podcasts I
say no to almost every podcast they get
invited to all right you don't know that
right I I get to run to three podcasts a
day and we say no to every one of them I
didn't say no to Oprah but right right
right or
Tony Robbins and Sage I saw that one why
did you say yes
the same reason I said yes to you all
right because there's a connection and I
I I've known you by because of your
GoDaddy ads and all that kind of stuff
right and I see your strength all right
and I just it's just to be fascinating
to connect right and that's so Tony and
I got together he flew up here once I
didn't even know him he just flew up
here took private plane flew up here
it's been five hours four or five hours
with me right and we became close
friends so well you never talk to each
other
I'm a bit of a Hermit I I said I am too
I'm an introvert by Nature other than
deep conversations
um which make me feel high like this
when we get done I'm gonna be buzzing
what um maybe you could maybe you could
just uh give us a little a little
anecdotal experiential story about what
you've found with the people that draw
you in have you found a Common Thread
between them that would help others
yeah what I find is which is really
amazing and somehow those are the people
I end up with okay like Russell Brand
like people don't know Russell Brand
they think he's a crazy maniac all right
and he is all right well he is and he
likes being he's he who's seen it as a
compliment by the way right he's deep
he's deep as they come okay and and so
is Tony and people don't know that right
I mean there's a big business power will
walk on fire push through your stuff
right but Tony's very deep and Sage is
really deep okay and and basically I I
had an interview with Maya Mayim Bialik
she used starred in some TV shows the
big bang and a couple of different
things like that and while she was an
actress
in those shows she went I think was to
UCLA and got her doctorate in
Neuroscience she's deep she's willing to
be open it not all successful people are
they're caught up in themselves I'm sure
you know that time right there's CL
they're caught up in themselves their
money makes them that way their looks
make them that way their popularity
makes them that way the fact that
everybody wants to dote all over them
right but then someone like you right
it's like you're obviously work on
yourself and you're an Oprah Oprah first
popular Oprah is I I am just blown away
over she's really really really deep has
a very very special person and that's
why she's so popular and then me it's
not that she's so popular and so then
she can attract people all right it's
like she's she's an extremely deep
evolved human being all right or soul
and so that that's what I found with the
ones I ended up talking to all right I
I'm flattered that you'd even put me in
the same
Galaxy as them
um thank you success the success that
you achieved as an athlete As a Race Car
Driver as an athletes all right means
that you Rose above fears
and all that stuff you know I think
about you driving 200 miles an hour 220
miles an hour turning a curve right with
four cars like the strength that that
takes but that's not strength of
suppression that strength of clarity you
go into what's called a Zone like when
you're driving you tell me when you're
driving like that there's a CL at the
clarities by the way is an addiction
isn't it you love getting to that state
right well it's just it's it's it's but
there's more it's more pure and it's
very it's empty but full you know
there's so much happening but you're
essentially well it's really as close as
I maybe get to having longer having more
duration of presence you have to so I
had a a Buddhist monk while I was on
this trip on the way to go meet the
Dalai Lama
um say that you that it was the I should
write a book called the speed of
Consciousness and that racing was my
moving meditation that's right and and
what I'm here to tell you is you can
live in that state
so you you retired from racing but don't
retire from that state that is your
natural state is that unbelievable that
is your natural that zone right is
Clarity that is because you had to let
go of her she can't be there you
understand that
right she can't be there otherwise it's
interfering with your ability to be
there and that's what meditation brings
you or that's what surrender the stuff I
teach right letting go of yourself all
of a sudden you realize I'm there more
I'm in that how would you like to live
in that stairs wow yes well this is it
look when I look at someone like Tony
Robbins on stage or somebody doing
something really great and and being on
and even when I've watched myself
whether it be in a race and like I
thought to myself the year after I
finished I was like I did that I was
group busy like I did that and then I
also look at things like speeches I've
given or presentations are being
interviewed or or just answers I've
given and when I really get in the zone
and really get present I'm like wow that
was it was really articulate and really
like smart and so I look at these
situations and I think oh my gosh you're
in US you're I would think in a higher
state of being or a higher level
Consciousness but more you yes and
you're allowing that to flow through
instead of this collection of stuff and
these stories and narratives getting in
the way of like don't say that or act
like this you just flow you got it I
mean you got it now the question is are
you intoxicated enough with that state
to say I would give anything
to live there I would do anything and
there's Beyond there by the way the
great Masters went all the way up all
right but they passed through those
States all right and that beautiful
that's not the highest you're capable of
being right well you said the owner and
you sit there and say that's the meaning
of my life
the experts for something explore the
natures but we talked about the fact
that you're there hi let's say you're in
that state okay you see that Clarity I
want you to go for a moment to that
absolute Clarity that you have to be at
200 miles an hour when a car's spinning
in front of you all right where did that
Consciousness come from
what is the source of consciousness
all right and that is not something you
know because you're it but you still
held down to your individuality all
right the great ones explore the source
of Consciousness whereas we're busy
exploring the object of consciousness
people say that
very much that that's the switch that's
what it turns over
so then
what is the final destination as a human
the ancient rabbis
would never write God
I don't know if you know that they're
right G underscore d
okay or G Dash D okay because who Do You
Think You Are
to even what is the word it's a concept
of something it's an apple well you know
that's silly you don't even have the
concept you know you know understanding
how dare you use that word not that it's
it's blasphemy right but that's claiming
that you know what it is and you don't
okay you may believe all you want right
but there there's this thing called the
knower of God and this thing where
someone has explored the source of
consciousness
all right and found out that we are one
you know it's all
it's all the same it's all the same
right there's a there's a there's a book
called Auto Body autobiography of a yogi
never heard that yeah all right yeah and
there's a chapter in that book called my
experience in Cosmic Consciousness oh
all right that now instead of talking to
me don't talk to him ask those questions
all right because wow right and that
that's the merger that that's the my
father R1
all right well maybe I'll meet you there
yeah I'll meet you there for sure we're
already there we're just busy looking at
this garbage thank you so much for your
ability to just
let flow through you what's meant to
flow through you as being a businessman
as an author as as a speaker as a
teacher it was because of this book that
I finally started to be able to access
the Observer and I'm not saying I do it
all the time
but it is the goal
well if you I'll ask this of you if you
ever read this I don't try to push my
books on people I don't do that but if
you ever read living untethered right
you get back in touch with me there's
send me an email do something because I
would love to hear you do that because
everything you talked about
said you understand what this is trying
to talk about right that's that's this
is beautiful it's so funny because
whenever I'm preparing for interviews
sometimes I reach this point where I'm
like not sure I'm like what do I ask and
like it
it inevitably leads me right where I
need to be which was asking apparently
these questions that lie within this
book and that will direct people
hopefully to reading this book and um so
it just shows me of being present and
staying staying conscious to the flow
and uh and and trusting trusting
surrendering and letting go and saying
this is obviously
what I should be asking
um and it's going to lead us in the
perfect Direction so I will definitely
read that I will definitely get back to
you thank you thank you so much that's a
pleasure to talk to you really thank you
I mean just so grateful you said yes to
the interview honestly I was when Jen
told me that you said yes I was like oh
my God thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today I hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe button